you wouldn't be a slave but you would
live a life of hard labor
you would be one of ten thousand devoted
workers
[Music]
since it took 30 years to build one
pyramid you would probably work on the
same Monument for your entire life
[Music]
which would be shorter than your fellow
ancient Egyptians because of all that
hard labor
at least you get to eat meat regularly
and get an honorable burial once you die
no matter your status you would worship
several thousand gods and for fun you
would play board games such as men or
Senate to pass some free time
overall the quality of your life would
drastically depend on your ruler and the
time period